Anthony: I'm here with Brian from Code 8, a team
from Uganda
and you guys have created a project called
Matibabu. Tell me a little bit
about this because this is this is a
really important project I think.
Brian: Yeah Matibabu is to diagnose malaria
without having to pick your body for any
blood sample.
It takes around fifteen minutes for a normal diagnosis
They pick a small blood sample, which may, at early stages, not be infected
But with Matibabu, we are going to
diagnose a blood stream for
sixty seconds which gives it more efficiently
In Africa you may find a hospital have no
power for 24 hours
and that means more children are dying
because a child dies every minute
of malaria. Malaria
affecting 160 countries
and in Africe it's ninety-one percent. We
are moving out to
partner with the associations, like The World
Health Organization,
so that we can plug into their distribution
platform, and then put up a booth like in a
village
where everybody can have this accessible.
Anthony: Can you operate it with minimal training,
I'm guessing right like anybody can...
Brian: No training you just have to tap a button,
which is absolutely no training.
Anthony: So lead me through how Matibabu
works. Brian: All you need is a
such a small device, though this is still a
prototype, that's why you see
that Arduino board around it. Anthony: And so why are
you using light sensor what happens when
I put my finger in here?
Brian: The the red blood cell is by concave and
when it's affected by the malaria
plus modium
it affects that light scatter properties
So if I put a red light through your finger at different wavelengths
I'm able to pick intensities of that...
Anthony: So you're saying yeah the red blood
cell gets deformed so light bounces off it a
bit differently
and you guys are able to see that
difference in scattering.
Brian: Actually not only the shape because the shape is
one factor
but also that biochemical properties. Anthony: And on a personal level, what what
made you want to tackle this. Brian: Uh
personally I suffered from the disease
for some good time and during that moving
you reach
a clinic no no power so they can't diagnose you. You move to...they have to prick
every time
prick every time and they take a sample
and they say, "We are not sure it's malaria."
You go back home you come back you're still feeling not
good
and then they keep on doing the same thing so...
Anthony: So you you could spend a day two
days just traveling from clinic to
clinic trying to get properly diagnosed
Brian: yeah
that's true. Anthony: So you're using some off the
shelf parts here. How
how inexpensive do you picture Matibabu
being. Brian: Actually it won't be
higher than twenty dollar. Anthony: So tell me
about you know coming from Uganda
creating this thing
to the Imagine Cup. Brian: Oh it's great. You
sometimes come and say you're in
Saint Petersburg, Imagine Cup, the final.
It's it's really
great experience. Anthony: Tell me about the
tech scene in Uganda. Is are there a lot
of people who are doing things like this
computer engineering
Brian: I'm its it's pretty hard because I it's
a a new
a new field in Uganda but you're trying
hard to put put up
um supporting. Microsoft has a
innovation centres
For example Microsoft  Innovation Centers
another pubs and other technological
hubs
done planted. So with with assistance
from those
we are fighting I to see that we devote
that the industry you can
Anthony: So cool. So if people want to find out
more about this, they want to know about
Matibabu how it
maybe help out in some way how can they
how can they do it? Brian: Actually we have a
a blog. It's matibabu.blog.com
You can find us on Facebook at matibabu
and Twitter at matibabu8
Anthony: Thank you so much Brian.
Best of luck for you today. Remember guys we
have tons more from Imagine Cup all week
there are some
brilliant brilliant innovations here on
the floor
including some games if you wanna see
those those are over the Rev3Games
at youtube.com/rev3games
and be sure to subscribe
here for more from the Imagine Cup